تم تغيير تاريخ نشر كتاب ماري ترامب في
وقت سابق بسبب
الطلب الكبير للغاية الذي
كتبته ابنة أخت الرئيس ترامب عن
عائلتها ، ولدينا الآن مراسل CNN الإعلامي
بريان ستيلتر معي الآن
لمناقشة هذا الأمر ، لذا تم رفع هذا
الأمر نعم  كان سيصدر في
نهاية الشهر الآن فجأة
Brianna سيصدر الأسبوع المقبل
الثلاثاء القادم 14 يوليو من بين جميع
روايات ترامب في السنوات الثلاث الماضية
، لم يكن هناك كتاب مثل هذا يمكنك
أن ترى ذلك  عنوان فرعي يتحدث عن
أخطر رجل في العالم تقول ماري ترامب
إن عائلتها خلقت أخطر رجل في العالم ،
ويصف
الكتاب الرئيس بأنه رجل
مدمر به عيوب قاتلة ويقول إن كل شيء يعود
إلى طفولته في علاقته
مع والده فريد و  الآن سيكون هذا الكتاب
متاحًا للبيع في غضون
أسبوع تقريبًا ، لذا قام روبرت ترامب
، شقيق الرئيس ،
ببذل جهد قانوني لمنع الكتاب الذي أعلم أنك
تحدثت إلى محامي ماري ترامب بشأنه
يخبرنا برنامجك ما هي حالة هذا ، نعم ، هذه هي الخلفية حقًا لسبب نقل هذا الكتاب إلى المكتبات لأنه كانت هناك معركة قانونية مع شقيق الرئيس روبرت يحاول منع نشره على الرغم من أن روبرت ترامب يقول إن ماري ينتهك اتفاق السرية الذي توصلوا إليه منذ حوالي 20 عامًا ، وهذا يختلف مع ماري ، ويتحدى محاميها تيد بطرس ذلك في المحكمة ولكن في الوقت الحالي تخضع ماري ترامب لأمر تقييدي مؤقت مما يعني أنه لا يمكنه التحدث علنًا على الأقل في الوقت الحالي ستكون هناك جلسة استماع أخرى يوم الجمعة في هذه الأثناء ، على الرغم من أن هذا ما يقوله المتحدث باسمها هذا بيان جديد تمامًا خرج من المتحدث باسمها قائلاً إن هذا التصرف من قبل رئيس جالس لتكميم أفواه مواطن عادي هو فقط الأحدث في سلسلة من السلوكيات المزعجة التي زعزعت بالفعل استقرار أمة ممزقة في مواجهة جائحة عالمي إذا لم تستطع ماري التعليق على أحد  لا يسعني إلا أن أتساءل
ما الذي يخشى دونالد ترامب من أن
يكون تصريحًا من ISA من
المتحدث باسم ابنة أخت الرئيس
نوعًا غير عادي من الأشياء ليقوله
بشكل أساسي يتحدى الرئيس
علنًا للغاية وأعتقد أن هذا هو
معاينة ما هي جولة الكتاب هذه  سيكون كل
شيء ولكن كما قلت ، فإن
شقيق الرئيس روبرت هو الذي
يتحدى رسميًا
المتزوجين وليس الرئيس من الناحية الفنية
ولكن كلا الأخوين يشتركان في نفس
المحامي